you guys are ever in Vegas man you go to
my house oh you live in Vegas yeah I
live okay Joe that's not you don't have
to say it like that don't it's so
obnoxious well how much is your mortgage
I don't [ __ ] know dude it's neither
do i cuz I don't have one that's crazy
they're all people all right dude all
right yeah I know we came at me well no
you did you're like I asked you where if
you lived in Vegas yeah I live in me all
right fine
the ridges is it a big house yeah that's
huge okay dude I also said that you
favor keeping us locked down for a year
so much fun is this I don't know man
we're sad told me no I didn't know hey
you got a what do you have a Gucci
windbreaker okay man this and you now it
needs to stop put that out now it needs
a stop you're dead serious man look what
what are your shoes a coin purse no dude
they're nautical star usour coins in
there hey is that a satchel you've had
that on grains oh you ride your horse
and then you feed your horse with you
you take your shoe up there's grains oh
say that huh these are golden for you
you can put water in there you drink
water oh that yeah there was that Carol
is that a camel's nutsack
yeah they double as a [ __ ] water
bladder sure hey can I get a pair of
Converse that look like a stump from a
tree dude these are golden goose be cool
they're moss green be cool they're
better than I usually wears hug you know
I will say this you I love you know I
love the way you think hey yeah I love
your thoughts man if your thoughts were
gesture outfits huh
all right does it make sense there's a
lot of you know there's a lot it was
really full contact back then I mean
watch the documentary you can see it
there much thicker now though right
there no no Brian can you not
participate in this particular
conversation you really that stupid come
is there any way we don't want off his
microphone just talk to the fighter and
shut the kid up no no I want to talk to
sports guys hold on dude please stop at
the greatest description of Michael
Jordan he goes if he had been on the
Titanic it wouldn't a sunk he would have
plug in hole
and [ __ ] running back mmm or anything
no no no I think I think in the pod I
think in the pot after that and this is
just some direction yeah 40 seconds of
complete sorry okay that slowly zoom
into it's fun right I'm trying to be
part of the conference it makes sense I
don't think it doesn't even make sense
what are you talking about the holes
yeah but is he the fastest man on earth
I just mean he's got will too you know
stupid you say every time I've said it
four times I that's a fight just
whatever like Johnny says that if I know
I wanted him to be like that's a great
metaphor and though he hated who you are
though who I know who you are you're the
guy like like at 98 you were well forty
Hey like in 98 when you were 40 no
you're a huge Jordan fan yes you were
yes and and then slowly it became this
thing where you wanted to be against the
popular right because it's fun for Brian
well I like seeing Gabe I just didn't
grow up now all of a sudden he went from
being a huge fan in 98 to like who's the
Michael Jordan guy and I had already
laying out reference for the Michael
Jordan alright alright they see a black
guy that's not how I talk man you play
baseball Michael Jordan all this [ __ ] is
intact
alright listen cutie thank you scare to
you
so I'm not scared of you so take it easy
let me explain something let me at least
warranty let's wait a bunch I know he's
got a lot but Joe maybe cuz you were
next when we were when we were in I was
at the Malibu chili cook-off that chilly
think he was trying to walk around his
family all the Chili's hundred of
hundred hold on no we can't move forward
after that it's a famous I don't be you
don't go the MAL malibu chick don't pull
and go they were like this you know the
chili what oh you what the [ __ ] why
figured you had money no don't do that
don't train to call yourself an elite I
did not show you
and you said the common cattle he was at
my audience but be real Adam suddenly
got swamped I really I'm saying that's
why I'd love to see one James Corden
start singing with him it's great yes
James Corden sing yeah Suze
yeah didn't you know that that's why I
show so big he and sinks it I didn't
know that he could say Wow I watch that
show
roxtor here we go again
did you hear did you hear Brian there's
breath I gotta see that
alright it's like your little gigs bro
no problem with the shoes the Michael
Jordan guy is that I'm sorry I'm not an
elite Oh Jorgie James Corbett all right
dude
yeah educate educate yourself oh yeah
I'll get I'll give it a look look I'll
get a look I gotta you'll see kitty
kitty see that's the hottest segment
bring him up let me hear him saying [ __ ]
you know he can see I've been on
unnecessary lockdown of really famous
because use a Broadway guy using Book of
Mormon now you just gotta educate
yourself on like the world yeah yeah I
don't know about you sometimes Brian
what are you why are you looking at me
with my shoes are these you cut in your
eyes I mean Jordans which number though
it's probably the Aviators you're a
really good actor thank you buddy I've
always said that about you have I not
yeah I've always said you're a great
actor I like when you gets offstage I'm
like you're a great actor I tried though
it's understand of state you're great at
when you [ __ ] you read those lines
good on he always goes to the club with
like a script soften me up and then you
[ __ ] you give it why didn't they be
huh bad guys okay that's great Wow we
went from a friend s hole real quick
from flower I thought we had it think we
are
I thought we had a thing where we do
this I know every time the show starts
we got that thing right where we're
gonna I apologize yeah here I'll call it
the fighter I apologize I apologize
already there I know I'm just saying
you're gonna be fine though you know
you'll be fine those things yeah I know
take it easy but that's not how I wanted
this to go
no one did man no because when they do
that they do that for a long time right
you have to wear your nails that long
for like two three weeks right
yeah usually I will you let me talk not
just one pocket on there let your
[ __ ] guests talk I'm sorry shut the
god I'm sorry I was looking at that you
go next god spider sorry and the cool no
come on man now we know we learned
something
well more you know I'll come on man no I
didn't know you know that smart
no don't smart right high kick you what
you're always smarter than is a bruise
like let me talk are imbeciles caught
the infants oh yeah infants infants my
favorite is you're smart you uh you're a
bit of a fan favorite I'll give you that
much I think the people like you can you
not massage the bottom of your thigh
whatever do that I push the same I
pushed and pulled as well we are hey
which is right here okay now listen
you're kind of a hold a weighted slam
Santa where's my chapstick there yo
buddy
everything turns everything turns very
southern hey man hey man I ever tell you
a man we ever tell you come on it's a
family show dude it's a family you're so
disrespectful what else yeah did you
just just covered your
curtayne
[ __ ] er what dude if you learned or like
you know I mean like you know like
Steven I smell sorry you're the one
that's talking about giving him knives
you got me a knife or whatever the [ __ ]
you get this [ __ ] leather shoes I'm
eight shoes at a craft
it's just favorite kind of being a dick
did Rosie get that shirt no it's not cut
it out cut it out
hey did you get the elk jerky jerky I
got it for a road that's not me dude
when I was in Montana damn it Joe I
swear to God I didn't give it to Ryan
now I'm like super Asian right yeah
really
this is Brian as a Japanese man [ __ ]
super stereo difficult that's probably
doing hey you gonna have to put
subtitles on it because I'm not gonna
move my lips there you go that's a fairy
oh but you like it inside huh yeah
you're laughing I'm just gonna do it
real quick yeah you ever say hey let's
look at an old picture of somebody and
that old picture as a young pitcher or
somebody but when you go hey can we see
an old picture Brian and you look at an
old picture Brian and it's it's just him
fold
you know man like even what do you do no
no I mean like let's see an old picture
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]